hey guys all the dragons justine and
today we are going to be unboxing the
new Amazon echo show I feel like
everyone is already unboxed it and I'm a
few days late but hey better late than
never
[Music]
there's a pull-tab
oh oh finite is full and well here it is
this is the echo show it's a little tiny
mini TV essentially it kind of looks
like one of those baby monitors or one
of the things that they have at the
hospital where they like here's your
baby like nope that's just breakfast
alright what else is in here
paper paper paper cable hope I don't
mean the new this let's open her up
[Applause]
I'm tired this is actually heavier than
I thought it's substantial the bottom
has kind of like a nonstick sort of
surface it's um nonstick or stay thick
it is a big Turkish it just flies all
over the place I know we're in the
kitchen I'm used the non-stick baking
band but this is it stuff it sticks to
your counter so it was a black because
the whole front is black and the back
would be white and I felt like I kind of
wanted to all match so that's why I went
with this one peel off this little tab
okay hey did you know that there's a
thing on Amazon it will show you how
much money you've spent total
yeah there is oh no you asked that's it
I don't know your echo two buns just
ready for seven all right
it is a touchscreen yes how does this
know that it's registered to me already
see Alexa show he met I don't want it
all confusing like cinematic shot of
this knife pickup it was like oh I think
it feels like Alexa time I don't think
the food is cold
Alexa I was up doing what do I do
this is taken a really long time
[Music]
so apparently you can voice like to your
friends and stuff I sent the message
with the egg and he said it scared him
Oh check your latest software update oh
I'm back let's continue I'm back I
didn't even go anywhere hey Edie
just wanna say hi introducing Amazon ah
yeah I get it
Alexa what are the new skills here are
three new skills first his Clea new room
chat with Alexa about all famed Nero
Kia's first-ever hybrid crossover you
can find a Kia dealership ask about
local authors and much more no give that
one a try no I don't want to ask you
about a Kia dealership
how much did Kia pay for that
sponsorship that's what I'd like to know
you said now I don't know what to do
it's basically Alexa with wait egg
prices hit 10-year low Alexa read this
for me getting your book from audible
resuming best seat in the house there's
two minutes left in the book i'm todd
grisham johnson Cotillard oh yes Alec's
not over being canceled Alexa plate
imagine driving shuffling songs by
imagine dragons I learn inside of the
waving green bin
[Music]
I can only set your personal photos for
your home background
tell me which photos you'd like to use
Oh God example set my photo album Hawaii
2016 is my home background how do you
know I have that hmm it looks like you
haven't added any photos yet download
the primes Photos app from your App
Store prime photos God how many more
apps does you have Amazon no wonder
you're taking over the entire world
Alexa play me a movie here's 13 hours
the secret soldiers of Benghazi is that
like in my I've never seen that
okay can i buy that soon so if you don't
have like a TV or an iPad or a phone
because this is basically the size of
your phone you can sit here and do
pretty much everything that you want to
do alexa show me my photos ah
Mady again Alexa next photo so these are
the photos that I updated look there's
you Maddie giving you kisses Alexa tell
me a joke why did the banana go to the
doctor because he wasn't feeling well
she didn't give me enough time to think
of an answer you gotta give me some more
minutes
Alexa evening my friend of course we can
be friends you seem very nice
Oh flatter me some more Alexa what's the
last thing that I bought on Amazon
there's one item on your shopping list
14 pounds of marshmallow butter okay
what hi welcome to the Alexa prize a
university competition to advance AI
it's early days for these social BOTS
and you can help them learn just by
chatting what would you like to talk
about I'd like to talk about my life his
life is an interesting topic you may be
wondering if this is a person or a
computer responding yeah are you a
person or a computer I think there might
be a few exceptions do you think that
you might want to be my girlfriend I
don't think I might want to be his
girlfriend I am a robot Alexa play the
trailer for the lost city of these
I don't let's uh stop I have nothing
else to do until I can find someone to
call Alexa call Edie Palumbo okay ed
pluma I mean the I'll go bed my video
yeah oh thank you
wait did I call you on the phone how am
I talking to you your voice is going on
at the echo my phone that is I left you
and run around late oh well use your
camera so you can see well here I'll
call you back and see if it works okay
as paluma your videos off from bullying
my videos thup your videos are my video
is on but no wait I can't see you oh I
see it oh yes look so editing on this
phone hook this Nathan
hey Nathan yeah what's going on you
doing really good thank you
dude you're gonna you're gonna want this
this is a real ed thing oh I just woke
up so my homie
smile wait what are you trying to show
me a smile every every echo in my house
one because I think he's going to get
bunch of messages I did it computer play
messages six from Justin zero look at is
here but what Matt God
it's the best video ever this is great
if I can steal my friends with yes
finally oh my god engine is favored huh
yeah no this is not based on I don't
FaceTime I will echo show only now why
are you just in your Amazon echo app
what it's kind of oh man show okay so
I'm gonna say that the echo show is
pretty cool even though this is
something that isn't really that
revolutionary it's like the way that
you're able to just drop in and I have
it turned on so you can drop in Annie
I'm pretty good angles they should be
like I'm not wearing pan but it's mostly
like muster up so like I could drop in
and it's the same thing
Thanks ah yep thanks for showing Alexa
stop edy from talking so that's it this
is the echo show it's pretty awesome
it's actually a lot cooler than I
thought and I'm thoroughly enjoying it
you basically saw me go from yeah this
is cool to like I'm not sure about this
I'm not sure and then now I'm just all
the way up here like I'm up here started
from the bottom here a little link in
the description where you guys can check
this out it also comes in
oh I'm receiving another tamam would
like to talk okay ed Palumbo hey did you
just drop it right
no I called I'm on how to drop it I
don't need it what what's going on
I was trying to drop in on you guys oh I
was just sending my video this is good
nice fun well you heard I hear well we
can be like making business together
okay guys I'm here with my friend Edie
today in my kitchen today we're going to
be making murder pies burger art I said
murder how I am to participate okay
murder pie oh this is great Jen come
here look at this okay but look come
here real quick hurry up you got it you
got to take a picture of this for me
turn out a little for Nathan hi oh my
goodness I am so into the echo show show
me more whoo as I said I hope you guys
enjoyed this very random video I'll put
a link in the description where you guys
can check out more information about the
echo show it comes in two different
versions so this is the black version it
also comes in a white version I'll put a
link in the description where you can
check out Lamar's video because he got
the white one and they both look really
cool where am I going to put this it's a
question because I want people to be
able to drop in any time of the day
probably like over here alright see ya
later getting this is a good new home
like anybody can just say hey
[Music]